now Roger Kennedy is five or six
different people in one person and he
makes them cohere better than most of us
can he just been extremely important to
the long now foundation he came in got
immediately what we were up to you and
led us pretty quickly to the mountain in
Eastern Nevada where we aim to build a
10,000 year clock and one of the reasons
he was so knowledgeable about that
particular mountain is because it was at
that time Great Basin National Park was
the most recent and smallest National
Park in the system and it needed some
attention and he having been the
director of the National Park Service in
the 90s was very well aware of this
hidden secret the only National Park in
Nevada and we're now privileged to be
part of that thanks to him over to you
Roger
the Old Testament lesson is from Ezekiel
34 eighteen through nineteen seemeth it
a small thing unto youth to have eaten
up the good pasture but you must tread
down with your feet the residue of your
pastures and to have drunk of the deep
clear waters but you must follow the
residue with your feet and as for my
flock they eat that which you have
trodden with your little feet and they
drink that which you have fouled with
your feet and the more modern text is
from Jonathan Edwards not the Jonathan
Edwards that is most familiar to us and
this text may not be one that you have
all memorized and it goes like this the
fields and woods seem to rejoice and how
joyful - the birds seem to be in it how
much the resemblance is there of every
grace in the fields covered with plants
and flowers and each sort of Ray's play
a distinct tune to the soul besides
those lovely mixtures that are found in
nature those beauties how lovely in the
green of the face of the earth in all
manner of colours of flowers the colour
of the sky and the lovely teachers of
the morning and the evening that is
God's earth
I commence with an homage to Stuart
brand of course this isn't the whole
earth to be catalogued but it is a
portion of it it's in Vaca t'v because
it indicates to us that from the very
beginning before humans arrived there
was a place here fifty thousand died
years ago people made it to Australia
and about at the same time they
commenced their wandering in our
direction for some reason and understood
by me it's assumed that the people who
did not walk to Australia had to walk to
North America which makes very little
sense to me
recent discoveries in the Channel
Islands suggest that they didn't
necessarily have to walk here either
but by 9,000 BC their migrations had led
them to settle into a number of places
where the Clovis points were far more
far more a hundred times more frequent
in the south and the east of the United
States than in the south and the West
those first artifacts that we can
clearly attribute to human presence
settled into three places and I'm just
going to ask you to keep kind of keep
these places in mind there's the bend of
the Tennessee River
there's the intersection of the Ohio the
Mississippi and the Missouri a place of
intense importance and I just want you
to remember that by 9,000 BC people had
gone there on purpose I'm coming back
over this country in just a moment but
at the peak of civilization in North
America before the arrival of the
newcomers there were very dense
settlements in the same centre of the
country at the Ohio Missouri and
Mississippi Center more people present
in that intersection than in Rome or
London at the time once again in them is
in the energy at the elbow of the
Tennessee and just below it and along
the Savannah River these were densely
settled places I'm just going to
anticipate the rest of this talk for
those of you who snooze because by the
time that Europeans arrived
behavior of our predecessors in this
continent had been such that in those
three three places there was no sites
meaning no architectural evidence of
human presence in the center of the
nation where there had been the heaviest
density or you'd like me to do that
Stuart I'd be delighted to do something
nobody it was called its archaeologists
have Prynne prone lately to call it the
vacant quarter the Savannah River Basin
had been similarly evacuated when the
Spaniards got there with DeSoto they
called it the Indians called it the
desert of oh good day it was wholly
uninhabited and the center of the
Tennessee River and below it which had
been a great concentration of population
had similarly been evacuated the
carrying capacity of the continent had
been exceeded now I'm going to go in
sequence now that you know the end of
the story before the advent of European
cattle sheep microbes and persons I want
to focus our attention at the very
outset of the evidence of human presence
the evidence that is in architecture
before the step pyramids it's a Kihara
in Egypt watson break was created in in
the Mississippi Delta this is the first
major piece of American architecture
it's now under a lot of second-growth
but there it is about a football field
wide we have no idea who was there what
languages they spoke there is no
evidence of any human bodily evidence
it's all gone
we have nothing about their DNA or
anything else except that they chose to
gather together for this purpose about
4000 BC they used however as all humans
apparently do they had a propensity for
making art they made little glazed gray
white cubes that was there are
later fifteen hundred years later at
Poverty Point in Louisiana things got
serious that is three football fields
long that is it Avenue directly north
and south by the by the Stars it's
parallels another exact one which passes
through an effigy mound of immense size
which is still there in the shape of a
Falk and there's another Falken down
this way and each of these concentric
circles if you sort of add up that much
dirt it's seven miles of this this is an
enormous site about the time of Troy
seven B prime is it Brad Pitt I can
never remember whichever one it was
that's who this is
they made objects and use them for
ceremonial purposes which required them
as all artists must to go to great
lengths to get them this material comes
from this is a steatite which comes from
Arkansas and Missouri but they went as
far as North Carolina for beautiful
stone to carve this is a little owl they
made owls and they made foxes and when
the last proprietor of the Louisiana
State Park that keeps track of Poverty
Point died after 20 years of presence
his partner told me that for four
successive nights a fox circled the
works
each night precisely at midnight and
went away our European forefathers
encountered architecture not so early as
that first the biggest pieces of
architecture that George Washington ever
saw or for that matter the biggest
pieces of architecture though Americans
who did not go to Europe and those who
did go to Europe saw work in the Ohio
River Valley this happens to be at
Marietta where the Marietta is
Washington's
austere core that settled out there were
great pains to preserve it they thought
it must have been wrong
Washington camped at the base of grave
creek which is still there in West
Virginia
these are immense structures far bigger
far bigger than anything in created in
Europe at the time they were components
of an immense and important sepal system
of persons who had migrated into these
areas and were related to each other
their works of art were composed of
material brought from the Gulf and from
the Gulf of California from the copper
from northern Michigan and Isle Royale
they were related to each other
intimately culturally and we have no
idea what languages they spoke or who
they were genetically but we do know
that they had deep sense of technology
and architecture archeology tells us
that they knew astronomy these
structures the one on the north and the
far up there is it Newark that's an
octagon that's a circle it's precisely
at right angles to another octagon
circle here I want to call your
attention particularly this little
circle up here and this one down here
because this is what trained our
forefathers to pay respect to the uses
of land by their predecessors this is
how they learn because of the intensity
of their direct experience to pay
attention to the possibility that you
can abuse the land and cease to be able
to support the civilization how big were
these places well this is the little
Newark circle that you saw out there
that's a golf course of course we take
care of golf courses so we have this one
left that's just the circle you can see
the - it goes to the octagon off that
way this is just to give you some sense
of scale these are very large this is
what Thomas Jefferson first knew of that
set of systems created by another kind
of person this is a model of Circleville
Ohio that little circle there and it's
adjacent square my attention was drawn
back to this material about a month and
a half ago because my pal Hedrick Smith
did a television
Grahame about Walmart's acquiring from
abroad its primary sources and closing
down a plant in Circleville this is
Circleville in 1836 do you remember what
that circle look like will there's
what's left of the circle but the
interesting thing about the citizens of
Circleville is that they created an
octagonal Town Hall they didn't pay
attention to what their predecessors had
done for very long however that's 1837
that's 1838
that's 1849 and that's 1856 the
obliteration of this of the preceding
circumstance and its replacement with
something else is characteristic of the
advent of certain kinds of views of the
land we supervene it this of course is
the floor of the Pantheon in the center
of which the man God Emperor sits under
the simulated dome of heaven and
presides over the gridding of the
Imperial Earth
that of course is the Northwest
Ordinance it's the same process and
pattern we shall overcome but in a
different way however one of the
characteristics absent from our
generations and present to the founding
fathers was a deep sense that they were
interpenetrating in their lives with
preceding lives lived on the edge of
what was possible in a continent now
what you're looking at are a set of nice
architectural drawings this is the
conventional Palladian model Thomas
Jefferson's characteristic training was
in this you have a central house you
have a couple of pavilions they're
linked together by - lots of bigger ones
smaller ones this happens to be however
Jefferson's version and it's not
Monticello it's popular for us that's an
octagonal house at the center and on the
wings
that's the octagonal house in the Senate
is an octagonal dining room an octagonal
set of tables we pay attention to
octagons and circles as you saw from the
proceeding line but we do it in a way
that the Europeans never did
that's the flanker it's not a little
building it's a model there's the - but
it wasn't and the entire estate plan is
that of Circleville Ohio these mounds
are Jefferson's deference to the world
that preceded him
Jefferson wasn't alone in that that this
is my magnificent photograph oh that's
Mount Vernon back there see but I'll bet
you don't see every time you visit
George Washington's deference to his
experience with the largest architecture
he ever saw the architecture at the foot
of which he encamped six times in the
Ohio Valley
his deference is his mouth which flanked
the entrance to Monticello and between
which he looked to the west
Washington sense of having of inhabiting
a continent in which there had been
predecessors was however nothing to that
of his colleagues and subordinates this
is what George Rogers Clark and both
Lewis and Clark knew of American
antiquity as they encountered it first
this is monks mound at Cahokia Illinois
just across from st. Louis at the foot
of which Lewis and Clark Kent isn't in
any of those wonderful Lewis and Clark
television shows why because we don't
pay any attention to the continent upon
which they came it's part of the
Pantheon ik instinct we did it there was
nobody there before well there was this
is bigger in footprint than any of the
pyramids in Egypt it's very big that's
it in reconstruction
this is Cahokia at the time in the 12th
century 13th in which it was bigger than
Rome
or London by population standards and by
architectural II infinitely more
interesting not as elaborate is that
surely but tio2
t walk on is a part of the same family
now you can't encounter that kind of
thing without wondering what happened to
it
what happened to those people and why I
suggested earlier that the center point
of the continent st. Louis the Ohio the
Missouri the Mississippi came together
at a place in which there was intense
human settlement from 9,000 BC
continuously to about 12 or 1300 ad
that's a long time for humans to be in a
single place at the end of that period
however they commenced to make very
intense use of the natural resources
available to them they commenced in
their bickerings to require military
architecture they had a defense budget
this is the Cahokia pne's defense budget
may be as much as 80 or 90 miles of this
god built by them out of what there was
left over when they had used the rest of
it to heat and cook by and when in the
words of Ezekiel they had followed the
earth by a hundred years after they
began building this is a simulation of
course structures of this kind there was
nobody there
the terrain had been wholly wholly
evacuated this is the part that Lewis
and Clark didn't see they didn't camp at
the base of this is just across the
river this is st. Louis in the 13th
century oh I could have shown you
Pittsburgh in the 13th century or
Cincinnati in the 13th century Anthony
Wayne put his sharpshooters on the top
of this kind of architecture in
Cincinnati Nashville there isn't a major
interesting Midwestern city that wasn't
a city once before this happens to be
st. Louis this is the
to st. Louis in 1818 let me show you
what I mean by that there's that little
bittle this is 13th century st. Louis
let me show you the equivalent to
Circleville yes is st. Louis a little
bit later with a little bit bigger there
we go there we go this is st. Louis just
a little later in 1842 it's a little
less of it and now finally st. Louis
it's a warehouse district
this is Mound Avenue well the point I
was trying to make is a simple one
there's a lot of political history that
takes place in the course of arriving at
the point at which population is densest
and most exploitive of the natural
resources available that political
history often presents itself in
architectural form now we're going to
drift away from architecture simply
because we now are come to people who
leave written records and who talk about
themselves in ways that we can follow
we're going to talk about Imperial
presence and Empire but we're not going
to do this starting out with Queen
Elizabeth we're gonna start out with
American empires don't need to do the
Incas and the Aztecs or it turns out
most recently the Maya let's just do the
first set of eastern Indians that got
modern military technology the Iroquois
who became an imperial power just on the
brink of their own national extinction
essentially and began overwhelming
everybody else the Iroquois hegemony
went as far as the Mississippi they
wiped out the Indians to the east which
is why there was a last Mohican there
was only one after them and everybody to
the north and south of them this is a
great imperial power the presence of the
expansion of the Iroquois represents the
presence of
gun powder and guns that's how they did
it
to the west of them the other advent of
new military technology the horse
produces enormous changes and shifts in
the whole nature of the imperial system
and it's not national Imperial systems
it's both racial and national we formed
Afro america in the south and the east
that's really what it is it's where
black people were in the majority let's
leave their condition out for a moment
let's just observe them present the
horse alters utterly the West expanding
from Santa Fe and otherwise we get the
russian-american system extending to
Fort Ross forts at Waikiki forts on the
California coast a very active imperial
power casting its eyes upon the silver
mines of New Spain New Spain however has
another kind of evolution very
interestingly I think and present in our
lives today this is not Spanish America
not at all it's a conglomerate people
evolving from the presence of a whole
lot of Spanish males and many many
Indian female and we got an entirely
different kind of populations very
different from that evolving and British
North America you nor the United States
you know all about so there's no reason
to spend any time on it
let's do spend a little time however on
the next set of forced movements of
persons the rest of this little talk for
the next ten minutes is going to be of
migrations of people because they're not
what we usually have thought them to be
for instance this set of person this is
the Sioux these are woodland farming
people the Sioux are woodland farming
people they are driven out of their
woodland habitat westward as are the
Cheyenne who are deeply woodland people
as they're ethnology tells us they are
driven out of the woods westward by
other folks speaking in other set of
languages that have the gun
at the same time that these people are
moving back out into the Great Plains
other people are coming into the Great
Plains from the north and the West the
Navajo the Apache the Kiowa they come
down in this direction know what's out
here nobody pays any attention
traditional American history to the
Great Plains why is that because there
isn't anybody there for a very long time
after the Alta thermal after it gets
cold and Greenland gets cold and people
have to withdraw back to Scandinavia
leaving little images of bishops and
other things carved in ivory the plains
appear to have been virtually as empty
as the desert of oh Cote or the empty
quarter back into the plains we are now
eventually learning come a whole bunch
of people who speak Algonquian languages
who come out of Idaho and go east not
West as traditionally we were trained
they do but we now know a lot more about
them now here we're beginning to get
into languages and genetic strains we
know that that set of people going all
the way east and then moving backward
again having possessed themselves of
firearms are pushing everybody else back
into the previously evacuated plains
North Dakota and South Dakota have
turned into badlands they were really
pretty icky after the great cooling
drying drought of the 13th and 14th
century but they were free of opposition
so these people could move in okay these
migration patterns are going on while
the political history we pay our
attention to was going on between the
United States and its competitors we can
zip right through everything that you
knew all about anyway
we know that in eighteen three we
purchased a place and an article three
of the purchase agreement we agreed that
there would be
Louisiana territory and because the
Federalists lost the debates of 1858 in
Louisiana or Arkansas it spread up into
the rest of the purchase and we got a
civil war which was not fought over the
presence of slavery where it was but was
fought over whether or not it would
expand into this wonderful new territory
where it wasn't necessarily going to
spread until political decisions were
made that it would in 1819 and 1820 we
began acquiring some other things and we
picked up Texas the Mexican Cession of
48 I think we we lost a wonderful image
I simply have to tell you therefore that
you must believe me that this is true
that if you looked at the image of the
Texas acquisition and the Mexican
sessions you would see that the Hispanic
Indian people of the Mexican Hispanic
tradition are simply taking it back
again if you look at the counties in
which those people are currently
predominant and becoming predominant
they are simply taking back everything
they lost after the oneís Addams Treaty
of eighteen nineteen twenty it's a good
thing to remember that politics has
certain recurrences in them now now
we're getting extremely contemporary
this is the last decade or so it's
actually a pretty good model of what
happened in their preceding sixty years
now this is this is not red states and
blue states in the conventional way this
is more interesting in that by a long
shot
and I suspect considerably longer in its
effects and its current duration the
center of the United States is emptying
out the population is flowing uphill out
of the center
toward the mountains and toward the
Piedmont in the east what is emerging in
the center of this country where the
population density has returned in the
year 2004 to that density that Frederick
Jackson Turner observed in 1894 as
marking the end of the frontier its back
in Nebraska and Kansas its back in Iowa
its back in North Dakota and South
Dakota we have returned the center of
the nation by evacuation to the
condition in which it was at that time
population had moved out of the Great
Plains again as it did after the Alta
thermal after the 1888 89 droughts and
blizzards when more Prairie schooners
went East than West for two years and
the Upper Great upper Plains emptied we
have now returned to that so what we are
getting in this great center of our
nation is a quite elderly relatively
sedentary relatively sedentary
population that has a sense of a
longevity coupled with resentment
it is like those persons who stay in an
Irish village while others depart for
the New World
this doesn't make them worse or better
but they are different where are they
going
well in the first place they're going
into danger and I'll come to that point
next it's a point I won't amplify very
much in this talk but it's very much on
my mind they're going initially to this
range of there they are going to the
risers having left the treads they are
going this way they went to California
but as you know two-fifths of the
population increase in the adjacent
States to California Nevada Arizona and
to considerable extent the states north
of it comes from out migration from
California the the growth of the
adjacent states does is not out of the
Midwest it's out of California this is
the this is the back flow this is the
back flow from California very
significant psychological consequences
of that - there is a measure of
disappointment that lingers in those
reverse movements I suspect that was
true among the Cheyenne and the Sioux as
well they're also going out of the
center and out of Appalachia into the
Piedmont not into the mountains in this
side but into the Piedmont out of the
six are the seven states into which
population has moved most rapidly in the
last three years six are the most fire
endangered states in the nation one two
three four five six one three five six
but they're the same state significant
because the populations that are going
to encounter that kind of natural hazard
as well as those who knew that
we're going to encounter your kind of
natural hazard are unprepared for either
the weather's hot / and dryer already
where they're going the vegetation in
precisely the places to which they have
gone is most inflammable and I urge a
little more attention to this because
and to this of course and a bit to this
and I'm going to show you a couple of
more images of this but the primary
point I wish to emphasize is that this
it's not just a dynamic system with
respect to humans moving back and forth
across the continent it's a dynamic
system with regard to the continent
itself the weather is not constant it
never was constant on a cyclical basis
and it certainly is not constant on a
secular basis and if you throw a little
more temperature add a little more
dryness this the world will change
radically a degree or two and you might
just look at what the underbrush looks
like and the Fallen stuff and tinder
between Charlottesville and Chapel Hill
sometime and then you will begin to be
clear enough that the problem of
wildfire in this country is an urban and
an eastern problem more than it's a
Western problem though in both places
its urban not country add a little
temperature this is the red movement
into the red peril now let's get a
little local it's not rural its urban
it's not Western it's Eastern and I this
is not an audience that has an intense
interest in Connecticut or Massachusetts
but if you were I would tell you
66% of Massachusetts is in what the
Westerners called the urban wildland
interface it's just safe now because the
climate hasn't changed much Connecticut
and Massachusetts have a higher level of
occupancy in endangered places subject
to a little climate change of any states
in the Union however that's not where we
are at the moment the places into which
people are moving this is population
growth and fire danger there's Tahoe and
there's there's a problem this problem
we'll return to in just a moment but I
want to suggest to you that in every
instance the Western fire problem is an
urban one and it's getting worse
both because the climate is changing and
because the people are moving into it
this is the corridor between Taos Santa
Fe and Albuquerque there's where the
fire problem is most dramatically of
let's just let's just do it with our
glorious imaginations let's not just do
this in the Front Range of Colorado the
precise correlation is between in
migration down to the zip code and
intense fire danger it isn't just that
the states that are most dangerous to
fire are the states into which people
are moving it's that the zip codes in
those states correlate that way and
there's a third factor of some interest
to some of you and that is that there is
a precise correlation between those
people who suffer from fire and poverty
not a rich person's problems and not
about second houses at Tahoe this is
about trailer houses in places that are
the only places you can get a place you
can
by that population that population is
exposed to the kind of dangers of losses
that this country has not seen and has
not anticipated I don't need to
discourse to you about seismic
probabilities nor about flood
probabilities but I wouldn't feel very
healthy leaving you with the implication
that global climate change is a problem
for Greenland it's a problem for Atlanta
it's a problem for Chapel Hill it's a
problem for Santa Fe for Taos for Tahoe
for Reno and of course drying this place
up that is going to produce some
extremely interesting consequences in a
place which will burn every year anyway
well I think the only way that is to get
rid of it now Stewart how do I get rid
of it because I have a couple of more
things I'd like to say ooh
glorious ok no no no we don't want that
we don't want that we can handle this
all by ourselves humans have migrated
back and forth across North America
moved by a wide variety of impulses
religious very important impulses the
evacuation of Chaco almost certainly was
the consequence of the collapse of a
theocratic system yes accentuated by
climate change yes of course weather
changed not climate change the
evacuation of portions of England and
their transfer of their populations to
the United States certainly occurred for
religious reasons the collapse of the
Hyuga
attempts to occupy the southern side of
the North American continent in the
presence of the onslaught of militant
crusading Catholic Europe brought to an
end a whole set of religious principles
and practices in the southern portion of
the United of this continent which had
been there for several thousand years
earlier religion moved people into Utah
and northern Arizona and a variety of
other places we need to take quite
seriously that people do not always move
just for economic reasons the market
does not resolve any truly serious human
choice we don't pick our wives for that
purpose we don't love our children for
that purpose
and many people don't move for that
purpose
either they move because they want to be
in the presence of certain qualities of
living that they vaguely associated with
a kind of world they aspire to inhabit
religion meaning the study of what you
take most seriously in my know of
neighbors words and a desire to comport
yourself in harmony with the earth our
related impulses though some persons are
made uncomfortable by one or the other
people moved because they had to move
because the places they had previously
occupied we're no longer habitable it
isn't just that the Cahokia pnes and the
st. louis ins of the 13th century had
exhausted the carrying capacity of that
enormous lee fertile region to support
them by using up all the wood and
certainly contaminating all the water
sources
it's that discernibly their skeletal
remains tell us they were becoming less
and less healthy very much like
Americans
on time doesn't obesity in that case
it's too much sugar in the diet and too
much dependence upon corn we know they
were becoming a more and more frail
people even before the onset of European
microbes we know that people's weaken
themselves in circumstances in which
they do not pay rapt attention to the
context within which they live this
leads us to the political future now I
am I am in many ways a fool but I am NOT
such a fool as to stand before a pause a
fall when all the gbn folks in Stuart
Brandon tell you about scenarios I'm not
that kind of a fool but I I do have some
suggestions as to what I think might
conceivably occur primarily because the
indifference to other and wiser heads
that will be before you shortly I looked
at an absolutely silly review of whether
diamonds new book in the New York Times
in which the I fear sometimes said to be
California propensity for techno fix
foolishness reached a level of absurdity
previously unknown to me let us not says
the writer worry
let us not worry about all the things
that the founders worried about as they
considered the presence and absence of
people who were no longer there
but who had wrought wonders where they
were let us not worry says the writer
about our own propensity to violate all
of the biblical all of the biblical
teachings about fouling there for and
here is one of two
outcomes to which I want to suggest a
third one is the apocalyptic techno fix
what my to human society be like
thirteen thousand years from now above
us in the Milky Way are essentially
infinite resources and living space
if the face of fossil driven technology
leads to discoveries that allow Homo
sapiens to go over to the galaxy goodbye
mom
then resources population pressure and
other issues that worry Dimond will be
forgotten most of the earth may be
returned to primordial stillness and the
whole thing would have happened in the
blink of an eye by nature's standards
that consoling thought we have so fouled
our nest that we can leave it one more
time
confirms the pattern of behavior of us
humans over this long story at our very
worst more scary than that to me is
apocalyptic resignation now prevalent in
some groups who prefer to have the
apocalypse soon and who treat the
probabilities of the deaths of hundreds
of millions with an equanimity which is
staggering to those who call themselves
in the name of Christ the notion that we
should be so indifferent to the probable
death and destruction of countless of
not just our species but other species
is an abomination in the eyes of any of
the major religions of our time any
serious person and so abominable as it
seems to me to require a response not to
require
simple indignation I think there's a
third way to respond to the continuing
impulses that have been present among
humans so long as humans have left us
any evidence on the ground or in books
to tell us of those impulses and that is
the capability of humans to reform the
political history of this country is
sequential but it's not linear the early
period of our national life was marked
not just by a revolution but by the
freeing of the slaves in half the states
of the union it's not a trivial
achievement it occurred very early
people of their own time freed the
slaves in half the states of the Union
they did it for moral reasons that we're
very explicit led by the Quakers but not
by the Quakers alone it's almost always
forgotten by people who think that
values based conversation is
embarrassing that it's sometimes
effective the second great instance in
our national history after let's take it
and see what's first half the first
period the first decade or so we did
pretty well we declared independence we
got rid of slavery in most of the states
then we had the first Jim Crow at the
end of the 1790s it was sort of normalcy
pre visited we got resegregate
women lost the vote where they had it
which was in New Jersey and in New York
blacks were deprived of the vote so that
by 1820 a rather heavily black voting
population no longer could vote it's
important to know that Aaron Burr and
Alexander Hamilton vied for the votes of
free blacks in New York
who voted a lot in the 1830s and 40s we
did some things that were perhaps even
more remarkable those of you who have
lived in a family that had an alcoholic
in it can recognize the enormous
achievement of that period almost
totally unrecognized by people who take
a despairing view of our national
politics we got rid of national
alcoholism not with legislation but we
cut average male alcohol use by sixty
percent most American upper class males
went to bed drunk in 1800s and less than
15 to 20 percent went to bed drunk in
1840 there's book about this it's called
the alcoholic Republic it's a very good
book it's point heads that when we get
our minds to things because we are
affronted by their adverse circumstances
in 1840 or in 2005 we can move ourselves
to do something about it
this was an addicted nation in 1810 it
was a less addicted nation by 1840 that
was also the period in which women began
to be noticed and required noticing
again let's remember they had voted once
oh I do have to tell you this one
pleasant little story my old friend
Aaron Burr and Albert Gallatin proposed
to Thomas Jefferson that women be given
primary posts in the Jefferson
administration of 1800 and Jefferson
responded to them that is a proposition
for which the public is not prepared nor
am i but 100 years later the public was
prepared for it and look taking a long
view we can reform ourselves in many
ways
even in the way we look at half of our
population the 1860s after all was a
period in which we summoned ourselves at
immense cost and blood and treasure to
abolish slavery in a war ultimately
fought ultimately fought for that
purpose it had been fought initially to
prevent the expansion of slavery
remedying previous political errors and
losses of nerve but in the 1860s we did
it
in the 70s we lapsed in the 80s we began
to get our nerve back again in the
Progressive Era we began to get our
nerve back even more strongly we laughs
in the 1920s we got our nerve back in
the nineteen thirties and forties
fifties mixed 60s and 70s that comes the
energy I firmly believe that we would
have entered a period of the same if it
had not been for 9/11 I firmly believe
that under girding in this country is
there for a recovery of nerve of a
recovery of purpose and have a
commitment to fundamental American
values I believe that for that to happen
a wave of reform and reassertion is
required I can't offer you scenarios but
I believe in my core that this country
is bent upon a course which is
remediable and will be remedied and we
will begin to look again at the world we
inhabit seriously and responsibly that's
the best I can do for prognosis but I do
want to suggest that we have some guides
toward it
those are going to be found I think in
some texts that we could well rediscover
but in order to do that the sense of a
text has to be expanded just a little I
think I suspect Spencer Beebe is going
to help in that a little because he
reads from nature directly but there are
some American texts of considerable
longevity among European Americans that
can help us toward that I read to you
earlier
some of Jonathan Edwards sermon about
the woods and the fields which seemed to
rejoice in joy he sang his sermons of
rejoicing in nature he sang them in
nature and he sang them to his
congregation we have come to think of
ourselves as being so committed to a
theology of dominance that we haven't
looked at the theology of dominance and
in its origins though talk about
dominance so frequently cited by those
who think we are bent upon a course of
extinction of all other species comes
from the first two chapters of Genesis
in which dominance is a description of
the role of Adam and Eve before they
broke the Covenant when Adam and Eve
transgressed their limits
when Adam and Eve decided to break
through the membrane within which they
were held to their obligations and
limits they lost their dominance there
isn't a word in the Old Testament
confirming that sense of humans as the
dominant species after the third chapter
of Genesis
the loss of dominance comes the law
after you transgress your limits comes
the Endangered Species Act after you
lose and break your covenant you require
some kind of order the sense of wonder I
think is the fundamental principle upon
which the next revolt and reform welcome
the wonder in the transmission and
expression of the creator's interest in
the earth in everything about us that
sense of wonder is an essential part of
the tradition in Islam in the Eastern
religions and in that kind of Christian
tradition which was disrupted in the
Enlightenment but which is still very
present in just a couple of very
familiar verses with which I would like
to close
Edwards emphasis was upon our common
habitation of an earth populated by
other species with whom we are partners
and components of the very nature of God
himself
francis of assisi this is the familiar
one not our more recent American one but
you all know this you could probably
sing it acapella praise be my lord God
for all creatures and especially our
brother the son which brings us today
and the light fair is he and shining
with very great splendor Oh Lord he
signifies you us do to us praise be my
lord for our sister the moon and for the
stars which God has set clear and lovely
in heaven praise be my lord for our
brother the wind and for air and cloud
and calms and all weather in which you
uphold in life all creatures blessed be
my Lord for our sister water which is
very serviceable to us and humble and
precious and clean praised be our Lord
for brother fire through which you give
us light in the darkness and he is
bright and pleasant and very mighty and
strong praise be my lord for our sister
the earth which sustains us and keeps us
and yields diverse fruits and flowers of
many colors and grass Jonathan Edwards
loved the color of nature the color of
the place we are and just before he died
he said that the reason why most persons
almost all men and women and those that
seem to be most miserable
love-life is because they cannot bear to
lose the sight of such a beautiful and
lovely world that is our natural habitat
that is the world we have sometimes
abused that is the world we can recover
once we take our role in this world as
seriously as did our predecessors
Thank You Roger
can we bring the lights up just a little
bit especially the spotlights up here so
we get more light on the stage okay
here's a question from Kevin Kelly we
noticed the absence of California and
any of your maps of ancient metropolis
and we got some now what what's what
happened all we know really is that
indeed during the Ice Age there was a
refugio in which humans accumulated
learning various languages more
languages than any other set of humans
in north america in california and north
of it what we also know is that there
was a propensity to build big in those
portions of North America in which there
was no easy living those were harder
places to live in in other places the
Pacific Northwest was easy living so was
South Florida and people didn't build
big they lived in big it was there why
bother I think you think there is a
sequence this is my question up
following on that anyway what we're
seeing now is the countryside is
emptying out not just the Buffalo
Commons and the high plains but
basically villages are emptying out
except the ones that are gentrifying do
you think there is a sequence like that
well as original metropolis is where
people were kind of scattered around of
tribal bands and then there was one
reason or another to go collect in these
Native American megalopolises no it
seems to me very much more likely
judging from what we know from skeletal
remains that we simply exhausted the
capacity of those places to support
human life it's also very likely that
when that happens and I think it will
happen again we will declare those
places to be cursed
cursed now there is a way to protect
land well if you if you if you think
about places that we think of as cursed
the dark and the dark and bloody land of
Kentucky is not paying a European
expression that's an Indian expression
it arises from what happened there
before literature it must have been very
ugly it was cursed
I sense a whole nuclear waste proposal
here I mean the best wildlife area in
northern Europe now is around Chernobyl
so if the nuclear waste instead of
burying at these can we spread it around
in areas that we would like to declare a
curse the animals will do fine we'll
stay out yeah it's great solution we are
as a nation and ambulatory set of
brownfields say it again we are heart as
a nation an ambulatory set of
brownfields we need to gather ourselves
together and purge ourselves and get
cleaned up this is a biographical
question for me
you were the head of the Smithsonian
Museum of American history and then you
were head of the National Park Service a
very different animal just across the
street but still for you
for the purview for the constituency
that you had for the frame of reference
that you had on North America
what was that shift like about that then
I do because he watched it I did not I
was in the you know in a heroic way in
the Second World War but I did not serve
in the Marine Corps so the Park Service
was my first exposure to that kind of
that kind of organizational ethos the
Smithsonian is a disparate collection of
people like a university not the same
thing at all
the National Park Service at its very
best is the collection of people who
believe in their mission are trained for
it are competent in it and are rooted in
particular places those are marvelous
characteristics marvelous
characteristics they are not accessible
in most faculties except in a few tiny
places and for me it was inspiring to be
buoyed up by a bunch of people who
believed in their tasks and had
considerable courage practicing it we
did not have an easy time and we don't I
remember you described Park Service
people as Marines for the environment
and it's this your wife you mentioned
that it's basically a 19th century
military institution yeah because it was
the military that ran it back then okay
a couple kind of contemporary political
questions that emerges from this 25,000
your time frame we live in a society
says
Vic why Sir Vic why Sir where are you
right back there I'm trying to avoid
we've live in a society the deals with
complex public policy matters in
simplistic I win you lose terms how do
we move such a saya T to engage in a
values-based dialogue once you are able
to connect persons to fundamental
principle that is benign once you find
in persons of any political orthodoxy
commitments to fundamental principles
you can draw forth from them sufficient
tactical as sent to parallel behavior
phezzan to complex a notion you can draw
forth from people of many persuasions
action that will last long enough to get
something done I don't think we
and possibly be presumed to agree on our
rhetoric or on our habits of thought we
can agree upon fundamental principles
and I think there's a lot more agreement
on that in this country then is being
evoked by the dull dry secular dialogue
offers a question without a name would
you please explain in more detail what
effect you think 9/11 the u.s. just
think it aborted the next cycle of
reform I think they got exactly what
they were trying to get we responded
precisely as any good terrorist would
have wanted us to respond and so it's
now several years later how long does
this affect go on do you think well we
have to that we are just we are in this
marvelous moment of transparent longing
on the part of a people that wants to
believe in itself again I it does not
seem to me that this is a bitterly
cynical me first nation in its aggregate
it's a nation that wants to be led
toward decent purposes and I just feel
that it's time to go ahead and be candid
in a passionate sense of commitment to
each other and to the earth it's as
simple as that
let's go
I want my party back I want my church
back and I want my country back your
party back
Roger you used to be a Republican and a
good one what happened and what would it
take to get you back you ran for office
I mean this was no mirror you know
Sunday afternoon republicanism you were
serious sure yes
reminds me that I got zombie licked by
gene McCarthy but I did win the primary
and Hubert Humphrey did say to be that
it was all my fault that he wasn't
president because if I had licked gene
he wouldn't have made it difficult for
Hubert so there you are it's all my
fault yeah I would serve three times in
the Eisenhower administration and a
couple of times did things for mr. Nixon
and once for Bush one I I believe in
governing and I believe in people who
are serious about governing not in
keeping other people from governing and
that's what I think we've got now
strikes me that's the important
difference this is the first time in
American history in my view in which
selfishness and bigotry have been Khan
joined in the governance of a single
political party we've had one or the
other and that's not my party we can do
some hand raising questions if you want
somebody want to raise your hand and
hold off hold forth yeah we got thing oh
you got he's got a point you sing it out
Paul Hawken has a question and he's
right over there
I want to stand up Paul sitting here
yes I think so the first of all we we
don't have much of an alternative
there's a there are there are two at
least two but there it occurs to me that
there are two traditions in American
environmentalism one is that if John
Muir and the other is that of Jonathan
Edwards they crossover in many ways it
is I think entirely possible to reach a
a determination to honor the earth and
others I think it's entirely possible to
do that living in a monastery in a
medieval city I think that's possible it
was possible it is possible it's I think
it's harder most of us when we consider
in our own lives the moments in which we
have had some transforming experience of
relationship to the earth and the other
a sense of self transcendence that has
occurred to us in the presence of a very
limited number of people if any in
nature but that isn't true of all
persons and it's not true that there is
just a rural or country or wilderness
environmental consciousness and
tradition there is a gardening tradition
as well we tend to be a little exclusive
in our in our sense of what our
relationship to the earth is and how
much of it we require in any event
like you I very strongly feel that it
would be a very good thing for the
opportunity to be there for that kind of
externally evoked moment of
transcendence and participation it's
both transcendence and participation but
my own observation in the last four or
five years is that the places in which
there is the most various resonant
determined view of a necessity for
reform in social and environmental
causes is not in people who are at great
distances from each other it's among
people who are very close to each other
in communities so I'll take it anywhere
I could get it but I think we can get it
in both places I'll take the hug I got
from Dave Brauer 4p the first director
of the National Park Service who thought
wilderness was a religious necessity
it's the it is after all a physical
Sabbath but it I will also take the
affirmation of the relationship of
humans to each other that expresses
itself both in nature and without nature
Puebloans
tend to do it very well in an urban
setting that's all I want my European
Way among each other with each other and
then into nature another handweaving
question right here
yeah yeah wonderful piece us young'uns
hated it but keep going
we do but I also think that there's a
role for rhetoric for the rediscovery of
a passionate rhetoric that and that role
is an absolute necessity if what we need
to do is to recover the gut to recover a
rhetoric that speaks to the tummy and to
the genitals and to the heart that is a
rhetoric that is a necessity it it is
not possible for us to be led into
sacrifice by an affirmation of
selfishness we're gonna win on this
because we have the argument for love
they don't they don't
the only thing stopping me
at this juncture is did that both of
those last two last questions as a good
Jungian I'm very conscious of having
heard both of those questions before so
I'm stopping to honor them to the extent
that I can that is to say I think those
of us who have a sense that we have
already heard an inquiry need to give a
particular space and to be particularly
slow in response so that it has a little
chance to have it's necessary breathing
wrong so I'm not going to give you a
fast answer to this would you ask it
again so we give it a little space just
say again what you said before
sure
this description that you have offered
could have been offered in the 10th
century at Cahokia in the second century
at Edina just speaking of American
places been in these kinds of
circumstances before we are offered a
sequence of opportunities to to respond
to the world's condition as we find it
one of and one of the blessings of the
human brain is that it is not it's not a
linear mechanism it's a mechanism that
that responds to necessity that's what's
called grace so I guess the answer I
would offer to you is that we can if we
are willing to admit it make ourselves
susceptible both to intellect and to
grace